[Music]
dr. if this fails he'll be permanently
paralyzed
ta and t9 are falling apart you can use
in Kadapa material construction is
hopeless I disagree
it caught me I'm still reinforcing frame
workers can't replace pulverized
vertebrae dr. Ouma the patient knew the
risks we continue
hey everybody is Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to watch daredevil
season 3 there's a couple really big
things we need to talk about there were
even some Spider Man Easter eggs
everybody asking for Spider Man to
appear during the Netflix series even
though I don't think that's ever going
to happen they can reference him all
they want so you may have spotted some
really cool Easter eggs in the
backgrounds of shots careful for
spoilers if you have not seen any of
daredevil yet we're doing a new round to
that spider-man ps4 game giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a Marvel related
comment on the video starting with that
big post-credit scene get that man in
adamantium lace skeleton very clearly
they're implying the bullseye is going
to come back in a future season I will
talk about season 4 during this because
of all the Marvel Netflix cancellations
Luke Cage iron fist everyone's worried
about them cancelling the other series
Vincent D'Onofrio the person that plays
kingpin said something today really cool
about season 4 so I'll include that in
the video but the really big thing here
is that they're directly referencing
bull's-eyes adamantium spine from the
comics what happened is is he fought
daredevil many times ended up losing
breaking his spine they replaced it by
bonding adamantium to it so when he
returned in the comics he gained a lot
of those extra benefits that Wolverine
has from his adamantium skeleton he's
extra durable his melee attacks gain
extra strength because they're
reinforced with adamantium strongest
metal on the planet next to vibranium
the other unexpected but really cool
side effect of the surgery is that it
leaves him unable to feel pain it's
somehow dholes fries his pain receptors
because of the way they're operating on
his spine so that means the TV showed
daredevil when he comes back to fight
daredevil again in a future season he
won't be able to feel pain and he'll be
extra durable and strong way more
relentless as an attacker and also
because he was sort of in the process of
becoming bullseye with his dissociative
personality disorder this season he'll
be a little more balanced albeit
swinging towards more evil alignment so
there were a lot of times when he was
fighting Matt during season 3 we had all
kinds of crazy trick shots banking
bullets hitting people with objects that
weren't necessarily intended to be
objects of attack he grabs a bunch of
glass shards from a chandelier before he
goes into his apartment to attack Matt
golly I think it came from downstairs
he's ricocheting the bullets
so it's just him using random things as
deadly objects I know everybody wondered
if they were gonna do paper clip or
playing cards after the Colin Farrell
version during the Affleck daredevil
movie they didn't get quite that crazy
but I feel like some of these moments
were nods to that the other really cool
thing about him getting this metal
skeleton I don't think that it's
adamantium in this moment as the
showrunner intended it because when they
shot this they did not have access to
Fox IP so that's why his origin story is
just a little bit different from comic
book bullseye because a lot of that
flows from the x-men comics so they just
had to kind of brush that aside but now
because of all the Fox Disney stuff I
don't think that's gonna be quite as big
a deal so maybe when he comes back
they retcon this a little bit and they
do say that it's adamantium but one of
the doctors refers to the other as a
yama dr. o yama
who is the person in the comics that
came up with the process for bonding
adamantium to human skeletons before
Wolverine got his adamantium skeleton
they're going for some really deep cuts
you may have also spotted the really big
spider-man Easter egg in the episode so
in the background they're in fog Welles
gym they have a bunch of old fight
posters that are lining the walls one of
them is a white parker boxer versus an
african american morales so that's their
Peter Parker Miles Morales Easter Egg
the cast was also talking about
spider-man recently about how they want
him more than any other character can I
say spider-man now fans would kill me if
I didn't say Spidey huh what Spidey
would be really nice to drop by
daredevil you sure about that
since the last Avengers maker I'm a big
fan of Thor people of earth lovely I'm
very popular
it's crazy funny he got a haircut and
he's like super powerful now I mean Isis
I actually really enjoy they're up there
fighting aliens and like Matt Murdock is
defending the crap out of ten blocks in
Manhattan like that's I think really
exciting that you can do this small
level kind of real people stuff I enjoy
our small level scale and I think these
little hints of libraries are the hints
the hints kind of like yeah make it
maybe if you were to make it too
explicit I'm not sure it'd be that
Vincent D'Onofrio is funny the fans
would kill me if I didn't say spider-man
and of course as you would expect he's
like hell yeah I would love to be in a
spider-man movie I'm waiting for the
phone call but no word if they're ever
gonna try and cross those characters
over because as of the end of season 3
kingpin is probably not gonna be the
villain going into season 4 he'll still
be around but part of the deal that
daredevil made with him at the end of
the season is is that you stay away from
the city I won't go after Vanessa that
doesn't totally neutralize him he's
still very powerful and he can be doing
stuff just not in and around New York
City because that's Matt's whole thing
protecting New York City but keep in
mind how grand and complicated and good
kingpins plan was if he can perpetrate
that kind of conspiracy for that long
without people figuring it out that he
can certainly do the exact same thing
around the world because they still have
that giant mystery Bank that he has he
still has crazy money so I don't think
that's a big issue going forward for
those of you that are worried now about
daredevil not getting season 4 because
of them cancelling iron fists and Luke
Cage the thing is is that Vincent
D'Onofrio was answering people's
questions on Twitter in the last day or
so because he also saw the news like
everybody else and his response was is
that Charlie and the others are just
getting started talking about the other
main characters meaning that they're
probably doing season 4 but I don't
think that Netflix is gonna make an
official announcement about that for a
while because they just cancelled those
other shows so they're probably gonna
let it sit for a little bit and just let
people enjoy daredevil season 3 Punisher
season 2 was supposed to premiere
sometime in the spring I would expect
that when they start promoting that then
they'll drop some information about
daredevil season 4 so no worries about
that I wouldn't worry too much about it
right now leave all your daredevil video
requests in the comments below I might
do
video about the fights between bullseye
and mad about how their fighting styles
are different because they actually do
really crazy stunts in the actor that
plays bullseye was almost cast as
Captain America in the MCU that's right
he was almost picked over Chris Evans
obviously it didn't go down that way I
think that Marvel made the right choice
I mean he's a great version of bullseye
but can you just imagine it not being
Chris Evans that would be bizarre
especially with all the talking Chris
Evans has been doing about Avengers 4 in
how it might be his last film you don't
want to give anything away and and I
should clarify that you know I I know I
did tweet something that made a lot of
people think that it was in some way
spoiler and I just I should clarify that
regardless regardless of how Avengers 4
ends I would have tweeted the exact same
thing you know it really was you know
that last day of filming was a very
emotional day and it was the culmination
of almost 10 years of filming and I am
neither confirming or denying anything
I'm working on a new Marvel video for
Monday that should post in the morning
only in the giveaway winner when I post
that click here to learn the truth about
why Netflix cancelled iron fist and Luke
Cage and click here to learn all about
the new updated phase for Marvel movie
schedule thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you